i've actually rolled with a lot of guys
who are a big fan of yours
i had a you know like uh last night at
jiu jitsu i had a guy who was like yo
you're going on richard cooper's podcast
awesome you know that's so i we bump up
bump into your fans all the time yeah
it's cool well there's definitely a you
know alignment there um
you wrote a
a blog post or an essay called i don't
care at one point um you know to the
point earlier about you know all the
attack vectors and people trying to mess
with you sort of thing and
i mean
i don't know when i came across that it
must have been five or six years ago you
know something like that and i've often
didn't you know recommend it to people
and i think i even covered that entire
essay in one of my before the train
wreck podcast a couple years ago um it's
profound can you can you explain the
basis of i don't care
well it's kind of it's related to my
book becoming a barbarian to a certain
extent uh
there's this idea that we're supposed to
care
about literally everything that happens
everywhere which isn't actually true
we're supposed to care about whatever
the media tells us to care about on a
particular day
and
that's you know that's kind of how we're
being controlled it's like you know
let's talk about the issue of the day
what are we mad at today
and uh you know it's so tiresome uh to
have that conversation every day because
someone's calling that tune
and
there's this idea that you're supposed
to care about all these people who you
don't know
and be deeply emotionally affected by it
you know and uh
the reality is we don't and so it's very
performative
for a lot of people a lot of people are
like oh i feel so bad for those people
like do you really though
you know like like you don't know that
like you know
obviously there are people who i care
about and if something bad happened to
them i would really care
uh but i you really can't care about
everybody in the world and what their
opinion is and uh you know like uh
so many times in the online and so forth
we deal with like i'm offended by that
and i'm supposed to care that you're
offended by that well i don't like why
why would i care about your opinion yeah
it's like if i don't know you and you
know so often it's like you look the per
then you you know zipper picture and you
know
what they say now like physiognomy or
whatever rules everything um you know
like you see the person you're like well
would you listen to that person in a bar
or like any other you know venue
and the answer is usually no you
wouldn't get that person at the time of
day so why do you care that they're
offended or upset like you don't respect
that person's opinion and so i i really
don't respect everyone's opinion and i
don't think most of us really do i'm
just being honest about it i think and
uh i think that that essay gave a lot of
people uh permission
to say
i yeah don't i don't care though uh i
don't care what you say and uh it's i
think there was a story recently about
some uh
uh some guy who kind of came off as a
chat or whatever who uh you know they
were interviewing him and he asked about
his opinion about the abortion issue or
whatever and he was like i don't know
anything about that i'm going to the
beach you know and
you know that's
a very a yeah
there are a lot of guys like that in the
world and i think that that's a good
thing
yeah
google it if you haven't read it just
search for jack donovan and then i don't
care after that and you'll find it it's
it's uh it's a great piece i mean you
know you can use it for dealing with the
way the world is today or if somebody's
bothering you or you know trying to make
their problem your problem there's any
number of ways that you can unpack the
way that that's written but it's just a
it's such a great essay it's a 10 out of
10 like mob just said in the comments
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you